[موسيقى]
اختراعاته وضعت حجر الاساسي للمحركات
البخاريه الحديثه حول العالم المهندس
والمخترع الاسكتلندي جيمس وات
ولد في بلده غرينوك باسكتلندا في عام
1736 لابن كان يعمل في التجاره
بدا واط في تعلم صيانه المحركات وصناعه
الادوات الهندسيه في لندن ثم عاد الى
جلاسكو ليعمل في مهنته
يمكن القول ان اهتمام واط بالطاقه مرده
الى صداقته مع الفيزيائيه جوزيف بلاك
مكتشف الحراره الكامنه
توجهت اهتمامات واط نحو البخاري كقوه
محركه وقد اجرى عده تجارب للاستفاده من
ضغط البخاري وتوليد الطاقه الناتجه عن هذه
العمليه اول اختراعاته كان صناعه مكثف
لمحرك بخاري كما اجرى عليه تعديلات مثل
المضخه الهوائيه وغلاف الاسطوانه البخار
ومؤشر للبخار
نالوات براءات اختراع عده من الحركه
المعروفه بترس الشمس والكوكب وقاعده
التمدد والمحرك المزدوج والحركه المتوازيه
وجميع هذه الاختراعات تدخل ضمن المحركات
البخاريه
لعل ابرز ما يميز اختراعات اطلاق اسمه في
الفيزياء لقياس وحده القدره حيث ان هذه
الوحده ما زالت مستخدمه في العلوم
الفيزيائيه حتى يومنا هذا
حصل على الدكتوراه الفخريه من جامعه
جلاسكو في العام
1806 تقديرا لاختراعاته
توفي عام
1819 بعد اصابته بمرض السرطان
[موسيقى]